If you've got a Bible, please turn with me to Ephesians chapter 6 as we continue on in our
series in Ephesians. Ephesians chapter 6. Well I thought I dodged a bullet getting Matt Tudel
to preach on marriage, but now I get to preach on parenting and slavery. So I got to the point
this week, late in the week where I just realized that was probably too much. And so we are looking at
what it says about children and parents this morning, and I've gone ahead and punted what it says about
slavery into next week. And so come and invite a friend. So we're here in Ephesians. Jesus,
we see, has changed our lives. So Jesus changes lives. He doesn't just change lives personally,
He also transforms our relationships as well. In chapter 4 and into the start of chapter 5,
we saw that He changes relationships within the life of the church. And now in chapter 5 and into
the start of chapter 6 here, we see that Christ changes relationships in the home as well. So last
week Matt very helpfully took us through what it says about wives and husbands. And this morning
we're going to see what it says about children and parents. Let's read Ephesians chapter 6 beginning
in verse 1. I'll read down to the end of verse 4. It says, children, obey your parents in the Lord,
for this is right. Honor your father and mother. This is the first commandment with a promise
that it may go well with you and that you may live long in the land.
Fathers, do not provoke your children to anger, but bring them up in the discipline and instruction
of the Lord. This is the word of the Lord. Let's pray. Lord, unless you build the house,
those who build it labor in vain. So Lord, we thank you so much that Jesus promised to be
the one who would build his church. So Lord, I pray that we would know your work here among us
this morning. I pray that you would build us as your people. Lord, I pray that we would know
your presence building us up together as the church, but also your presence in our homes as well.
So I pray that you would speak for your servants who are listening in Jesus' name. Amen.
Well, yesterday Gideon and I went to a falconer's meetup. And so if you're not familiar, you're with
falconery. It's essentially hunting with birds of prey. And if you're thinking, well, I didn't know
this about Brandon, that he's a secret falconer, I'm not. It was fascinating to see that we met
somebody who is a falconer and told us about this meetup that was happening with falconers
from all across Alabama. And so why not? So we went to it and met some of them, met some of their
birds. And we were there. But as we were there, and I started thinking, well, this is pretty
interesting. Maybe I should get into this. And so I googled, what does it take to become a falconer?
And it's more than I anticipated. So I mean, there's a whole lot that goes into it. It's
not just like, oh, I'm going to go grab a hawk and see what happens. In order to actually
be able to hunt with a hawk, you've got to have, let's see, you've got to be able to take
certain exams where you know all about ornithology and you know about conservation and you know
about these particular birds. And so there's that exam that you've got to do. There's also
permits you've got to get. You've got to have licenses. And not only that, you've got to
find somebody who's going to be willing to sponsor you who is a licensed falconer.
And not only are they going to have to sponsor you, but you need somebody who you can be
an apprentice of for the next two years in order to then finally get your license to be a falconer.
And on top of that is going to be all the money you're going to spend and everything that you're
going to have to buy and the enclosure you're going to have to build and on and on it goes.
There is a lot involved in falconry enough to give me pause to think whether or not that's
my life's calling. But after thinking about all this and thinking about preaching on this
text this morning, it reminded me of how unqualified I felt to look after my very own child.
When we went to the hospital to have our first baby, it felt like bank robbery to step out of
that hospital with a baby that they would trust us to look after this child. I mean looking at
everything will be required to take a hawk home with you to look after it versus everything
that was required of us to actually look after a human baby. It seems like there's a lot more
involved in the falconry side of things. But so I'm thinking like I felt so unprepared. All we had
to bring I think was a car seat to show that we could take the baby safely home and you take the
baby home and it's like well now what? And so we have this baby and the thing is it wasn't as
hard as I thought it would be. It was much harder. The thing is is like not just looking after a baby
but as they grow there's different stages and complexity becomes with those different stages of
growth over the years and then you add other children into the mix just adds the complexity
of their own personalities and the unique ways the Lord has made them. So all of that is in
the mix when it comes with parenting. So it's difficult for parents but I must also say
keeping that in mind it's also difficult for children too. Like as parents are figuring things
out well the kids are in the home of the parents who are still figuring things out as well. So as we
come to this section on children and parents thinking about how difficult that can be as well
it's important for us to remember the foundations of grace that have been laid for us in the
book of Ephesians because that speaks to us not just as people but as parents and as children
of parents as well. So everything that we need to live the life that God has called us to has been
given to us freely in Jesus. He's provided all that we need. So we've seen that God saves us by his
grace. So his grace is freely given to us in Jesus not because we are deserving. He shows grace
to the undeserving. He saves sinners. So if you feel like you're not quite living up to what
you would hope to live up to as a child or as a parent there is grace for you in Jesus. He shows
grace to the undeserving. But also God's grace empowers us to grow in the likeness of Jesus.
So God empowers us by his spirit to help us to follow the model that we have in Christ
of sacrificial self-giving love in the home. I don't know if you've ever read anything
by Paul David Tripp. He's written some really helpful things on the family. So I definitely commend his
work to you. But he speaks of Jesus's self-sacrificing love for the undeserving as the ultimate model
for parenting. So Jesus cross in his work there as the ultimate model. The thing is the more
that you see of him the more you're brought to the end of yourself. Like if that's the model
Jesus is self-sacrifice on the cross out of love for us. Well then you might look at that and think well
I can't do this. You might have thought well I wasn't doing a great job anyway but if that's
the standard I can't do this. I can't live up to that. But here's the thing. It's a good thing to
get to the end of yourself. The good news is about being brought to the end of yourself is that
you then learn to depend not on yourself but on the grace of God. Because there on the cross we see that
undeserving people, people who don't live up to their standards, who don't live up to that model
are invited to come to experience God's love. And so we come to Christ we run to him and we say
I can't do this. Lord help me by your grace and make me a channel of your grace to my children
or to my parents or to those around me in the life of the household of God in the church.
But here's the point I want to start with. Children and parents are both in need of God's grace. We
are both in need of the gospel of grace. What Paul says here then especially in light of what he
has already said shows us what it looks like to have a gospel saturated and a gospel shaped home.
That's what we're aiming at, a gospel saturated and a gospel shaped home. A home where we know the
forgiveness of Christ but also we're growing together in the lightness of Christ. Okay so let's
look at it together. So he speaks to children first and then to parents. So that's your two
point outline this morning, children, parents. All right so first of all children he begins
in verse one but let's pause there before we get on to what is said to children to see that
children are being spoken to here. I don't want to miss this point here is that Jesus welcomes children.
The Bible speaks about God's love for children. So Matthew chapter 19 verse 14 Jesus famously said
let the little children come to me and do not hinder them for to such belongs the kingdom of
heaven. Jesus invited children to come to him when others other disciples were saying no like
get away he was saying no let them come to me. To such belongs the kingdom of heaven. But not only
does he welcome children he calls the church to be a welcoming place for children. Jesus also said in
Mark chapter 9 in verse 37 whoever welcomes one of these little children in my name welcomes me.
So our welcome of Christ is seen in how we treat and welcome children. So what Paul is writing here
remember is in the context of the gathered church he is writing with the implicit assumption that
children are present and integral to the to the life of the church. So the expectation here is that
they have been welcomed and included and are being taught in the life of the church
because he's saying hey children he's expecting they've been welcomed. And I've already said it this
morning but I do want to praise God for the children that he has brought into Trinity from the
start and we want to do everything that we can to see that they are welcomed that they are
included that they are instructed here. And also while this isn't prescribed in Scripture
but passages like this one where children are addressed within the context of the gathering
of the church is why we've decided to have children with us at the start of the service
especially as we gather here together but also why we want to have age-appropriate teaching for them
as well so they are instructed in the Lord. So we're trying to strike a balance there.
But as not only a pastor but a parent I want to say thank you to all of you
who have been volunteering in the children's ministry and leading the way in that. And that is
I realize a majority of you in here so I thank you so much for that the work that you have done
and those that have been served by you have been so helped it is so valuable and the Lord is honored
in that. And that by the way it extends beyond serving an official like kids ministry like
all of our children need not only parents but cousins and aunts and uncles and grandparents
in the Lord. We all need the family of God around us and that includes our children too. So even if
you're not formally serving in that way the Lord can use you in the lives of some of the younger
members here. Okay but what is said to children? Let's read it together once again.
Notice it says children obey your parents in the Lord for this is right honor your father and mother.
This is the first commandment with a promise that it may go well with you and that you may live
long in the land. All right so let me speak to the children who are still here at the moment
in our service now. So I'm going to pause to just say that if you're still living in the home
of your parents I've got something to share with you. And Lauren if you could explain it to
Finn. Appreciate it. There we go. So there's three things here it says there's this there's someone
for you to know. It talks about something for you to do and something for you to look forward to.
Okay something for you to know or someone for you to know something for you to do something for
you to look forward to. So someone for you to know. So Paul talks about parents here and it's
good to get to know your parents and I'm sure there's still lots of interesting things that you
don't know but there's someone who is far more important for you to get to know and that is the
Lord Jesus. It speaks about him here. It speaks about Jesus but then it says something really
strange it talks about us being in the Lord. So what could that possibly mean to be in the Lord?
And then I was thinking earlier I was thinking actually all of our lives began in someone else.
So our lives began in the womb of our of our mother and so our life when we got started was
totally dependent on her life. So everything we needed came from being in her and there was even
like an umbilical cord like where all the nutrients they were needing to keep us alive.
So we were actually connected to our mother we were in her and so the Bible talks about being
in the Lord. He's talking about the a new spiritual life that we are given through Jesus that lasts
forever. So we deserve to be cut off from God because of our sin. Jesus came and he died for our
sin and he rose again to reconnect us to God and he is our source of life. So the way that we have
eternal life is by being connected to Jesus by saying that we're sorry for our sin calling
out to Jesus and asking him to save us to forgive us and to give us eternal life. When you do that
you will know his love for you. You will know him taking care of you and you will know him helping
you. You'll find that God is a better parent than any parent you could ever imagine. So
are you in the Lord? Have you come to know Jesus? I hope so. But also there's something
for children to do here. Alright so what is that? Children obey your parents in the Lord for this is
right. Okay what is that? Well first of all obeying your parents by the way does not make you a Christian.
We can't do anything to get eternal life. God doesn't welcome us because we obey him but because
he loves us. But when you come to know Jesus one of the things that Jesus does is he helps you to do
those things that are pleasing to him. He helps you to obey your heavenly Father. And one of the
best ways to start doing that is to start doing that where you spend a lot of your time and that
is at home with your parents. So God has given parents an authority over children or over
their own children. So obedience is what he calls children to. Now we may not always like that and
it's not always easy but it's what God has told us to do. It's how he's designed it. It is right.
So we should want to obey our parents not because we think they always get things right or because
they know everything. We obey our parents because we want to obey God. We want to obey Jesus.
He is perfect. And so we look to him for the help that we need to obey. But we also look to him for
the help that we need to say sorry when we have failed to do that. And parents fail and children
do as well but he welcomes us and helps us to say sorry to one another and to God and to know
his forgiveness and his help. But doesn't just say to obey your parents it says to honor them.
That means that deals with our attitude and treating them with respect and how we treat them and
particularly how we speak to them. We're to treat them with respect because that's what the Lord
commands of us. And that's whether they we feel they deserve respect or not. And by the way this
is moving from just general children to adult children as well because when it comes to honoring
the way we honor when we are younger children is by obeying our parents. But the command to honor
then stretches throughout the rest of our lives. So this is for adult children as well. So we have
to ask ourselves like how do I speak of my father or of my mother. Am I honoring them and how I
speak to them or about them. Then when it comes to aging parents as well there's a God giving
responsibility to honor them and how we then care for them in their old age. And having lived in
different places around the world it's fascinating just to know that in a lot of non-western contexts
this is something that other cultures take very very seriously. They have a high regard for not
only their parents but for just the elderly in general in their populations and seek to honor
them and respect them. And it's worth us considering in our western context whether or not we have a
blind spot in that area. And just to prayfully think about how we can honor our parents and
older folks among us. Because doing so honors the Lord. But there's also something to look
forward to. So we know Jesus seek his help to obey our parents and then to honor them as well.
And we do that with something to look forward to. So honoring your parents is connected with future
blessing in Scripture. It says honor your father and mother. It's the first commandment with a promise
that it may go well with you that you may live long in the land. Now what does that not mean?
It does not mean that every child who honors their parents will live a long life in the land of
the free and home of the brave you know here in America. This is this is a commandment
given specifically in a promise to the people of Israel. The Paul is applying this in a broader way
here too. So what is going on here? So the people of Israel were promised that it would
things would go well with them and that they would live long in the land of promise if they were
honoring their parents. So how do we apply this? Well could I just say
this is an area where there's lots of disagreement about how this works out
in practice. What this could possibly mean. But let's walk through areas that we know are
absolutely true. One is it almost certainly does not mean that every child who disobeys or disrespects
their parents will have a short life. That's not what it is saying here.
I'll leave that there. What it says here though is certainly true in a in a general sense.
Okay so what do I mean by that? There are blessings that accompany
obeying and honoring your parents that you would not experience otherwise without obeying and honoring
them. In other words learning the path of obedience to Christ early in your life will save you from a
lot of hardship and will set you up well for the rest of your life. And in terms of the
decisions that you end up making following that path it could end up literally saving your life.
In the future. So this is true in that general sense of blessings that come.
But let me remind you of what we saw in Ephesians chapter one. What are the greatest blessings
that we have been given? Well there are spiritual blessings that are ours in Jesus.
So it seems there's we're being pointed to those spiritual blessings too. The
lands that we are looking forward to living forever in is what we spoke of as our inheritance.
So our hope as believers is that we will one day live in our eternal
heavenly home with our Father. We will dwell with him forever in the new creation.
And our obedience to Christ is pointing to the fact that we are his children and
that is where we are heading. So there's hope given when it's good and when it's hard
we are going to be with him forever. So that's what he says to children here.
What about parents? What what is spoken of here to parents? Well earlier I mentioned that
this passage indicates that both children are present, the children are present in the life of
the church. But that doesn't mean that the discipleship of children is entirely given
over to the church. The responsibility to disciple children belongs first of all to parents.
To parents. So part of the role of the church is to encourage parents in the discipleship of
their children. I was reading a just it was it was describing a newspaper cartoon that was out there
and it was of this 18 year old boy and he was on the on the hood of a police car and his
hands were behind his back and he was handcuffed and behind him his mother just had her hands
up in the air and she was crying out to God and she was saying oh God where did the youth pastor go wrong?
So in other words that her mindset was I dropped him off at the youth group.
Where did the youth pastor go wrong? So that that could be the mindset of many of us. We could
think that well as long as we delegate the discipleship of our children to others then
at least they're covered that way. Maybe it could be a church, could be kids ministry here, could be
a another Christian organization or school or something. We think as long as that base is
covered we're off the hook. Now don't get me wrong that is far better than nothing.
And the church does have a key role in the life of our children as we have already seen.
And I would much rather see children reached here and taught here than not at all.
So praise God for when that happens. But at the same time parents have a God given responsibility
to disciple their children. So we should accept that responsibility from the Lord but also just
as a side note research shows that the number one influence in the life of a child that's going to
then carry on into adulthood is not their peers actually. It is their parents. That is where
the influence is and that corresponds as well to the influence of their spiritual life too in terms
of like pointing them to the Lord. But you can look into that later if you would like.
But what is said here specifically? He says fathers. We're going to have to pause there again.
Fathers. Why do moms get off the hook here? And what is going on with him talking about fathers
here? Well the word father is occasionally used in Scripture to speak of both parents.
So you look in Hebrews chapter 11 verse 23 in the ESV it's actually translated parents there
but it's the same word used for fathers here. So it can be used to speak generally of parents
like we sometimes hear like in Scripture speaking about brothers but referring clearly to brothers
and sisters within the life of the church. So the same thing can happen. But then again he's
already made a distinction in the passage itself between fathers and mothers and now he's
repeating fathers. You go earlier you see that husbands were given a responsibility to be
spiritual leaders in their home. So how do we take all that together? Well taking that together
it seems to be what is going on here with addressing fathers specifically instead of just saying
parents is that he is addressing fathers specifically but about responsibilities that apply
generally to both parents. In other words everything he's saying applies to both father
and mother but there is a God given responsibility for fathers who are in the home to lead the
way in the nurture of their families. So what are these responsibilities that are given to both parents
that hopefully dads take the lead in? Well first of all we're not to be harsh with our children.
So chapter 6 and verse 4 fathers do not provoke your children to anger. So yes as we've said
already parents have authority in the home but that authority must be restrained. So we're
saying to children you need to obey and respect the authority of your parents but the parents
he's saying you need to restrain that authority. Now this was very different and counter cultural
in the Roman Empire. When you read about what happened with children in the Roman Empire it's
unreal. Fathers literally had limitless power over their children. If they wanted to disown them
it was totally their right to disown their children. If they wanted to sell them into
slavery it was totally their right to sell them into slavery. If there was some issue whatever it
was and they decided well actually no the death penalty is what my child deserves or actually
I wanted a boy instead of a girl or something like that. Fathers actually had a right to
dispose of their children and to kill their children. So Paul is writing here and he is saying
restrain what your culture approves of that should not be the case among you parents
in your relationship with your children. So he's calling fathers and parents to not abuse their
authority by treating them their children in ways that are harsh or discouraging. So he's going
beyond just saying like don't like disown them or sell them or something. He's saying don't
treat them harshly. Don't be discouraging in how you deal with them. Don't provoke them to
anger. So what are some of the ways that that can happen? Now there are dozens of ways
that we could provoke our children to anger and that's just like the ways I can think that I've
gotten it wrong and continue to do so. So I'm speaking here as a struggling parent but we'll
let's see these. Let's just take two okay. Two ways we can provoke our children to anger
that are wrong. One is over-disciplining over-disciplining. So it could be a home where
it's all rules and very little relationship. You have an overbearing father and mother that
makes demands or speaks and makes an unreasonable demands or speaks in ways that are discouraging
where the atmosphere is one of always nitpicking every little fault or shortcoming or or being
over the top or excessive in in punishments that are dealt out. So that kind of being
overbearing or a kind of over-disciplining. But if that's true and you could probably guess
what the other one is going to be is also an under-disciplining. Under-disciplining. That kind
of a total hands-off approach to parenting. So it's the responsibility of parents we see here to
require the obedience of their children and that requires setting boundaries. It's
exasperating for children when they don't know what the boundaries are or what the consequences are
and what can then happen is that it's just unpredictable and that's a that's a frustrating
way to live or or even worse they can end up being at the whims of a parent who's just can
lash out at any moments just when they when they've had enough is when the correction happens
as opposed to those kind of clear boundaries that are there. So it can be over-disciplining
or under-disciplining. We're not to treat our children in ways that are harsh or discouraging.
So that's what we're not to do. What are we to do? So positively we are to nurture our children.
So let's see this in verse 4. It says, so don't provoke them to anger but bring them up
in the discipline and instruction of the Lord. So we're told what we're to withhold but
also we're told what to give here. So we're to bring them up. The word bring them up is the same word
that Paul used earlier to speak about a husband's love and care for his wife that is modeled on
Christ's care for his church. So you have that same thing. So Christ loves the church laid down
his life. Husbands are to care for their wives in this way and it's flowing on here with
children as well when he said bring them up. Same exact language as being used here. And
actually depending on the context the word that's used for bring them up can actually mean
providing them with food. All right. So and that's part of our God given responsibility as
parents. You know 1st Timothy 5.8. We're to care for our children's physical needs. They're
emotional needs as well. We're to God has given us whole persons to look after. And so that's
part of our parenting responsibility too. But there's also a kind of nourishment that can only
be provided by Christian parents. So there's something uniquely Christian about what he is saying
here. And that is the nurture of the Lord. So man shall not live by bread alone and neither shall
our children were to provide them with what they need not only to develop and grow physically
but spiritually. And if we neglect that word neglecting it to our children's peril.
And it may not be as obvious as looking at physical neglect but it is just as real.
And that could happen with a passive approach to parenting kind of just leaving them to their
own devices. So we were to take an active role in our children's lives doing everything that we
can to nurture them towards maturity not just as adults but as followers of Christ.
So what does that involve? How are we to nurture through discipline and instruction says here.
And discipline here is referring to both training and correction. And once again the correction
side of things is with restraint with the good of our children in view. Hebrews chapter 12 verses
5 to 11 speaks about our heavenly Father disciplining us with our good in view.
But also he speaks of instruction here. This is giving teaching or giving counsel.
And that can include general life advice. That could be part of it too. But it's also teaching
them about the Lord opening up the truths of God's word to them. One of the best places to go
in Scripture to see that is going back to Deuteronomy 6 and what God says to the people of Israel
there. It's where he says, here Israel the Lord your God the Lord is one. He says you're
to love the Lord your God with all your heart your mind your strength.
But then he also goes on to say this verse 7. You're to teach the word that you've hidden in your
heart diligently to your children. You shall talk of them when you sit in your house and
when you walk by the way and when you lie down and when you rise. So he's saying make the
most of every opportunity to teach your children the things of the Lord. It could be dinner times,
bed times, car rides. It could be through listening to good Christian music or it could be
reading Scripture with them, giving them godly counsel, asking them thoughtful questions.
And all of that in a way that models the truth that we are saying. We are teaching
and showing them what it looks like to follow Christ. Opportunities abound if we will seize them.
So it's the context of a loving Christ like relationship that we're then teaching them
the ways of Lord. But one thing I love about this passage in particular
is that it shows where our teaching of our children must begin.
You can look back at Deuteronomy 6 remember where it starts. It says this is who your
God is. You love God with all your heart and you hide his word in your heart.
And then you make every opportunity to teach your children. In other words, this is where it must
begin. It must begin with our own walk with the Lord. As parents this is what we need more
than anything else. This is what our children need more than anything else is for us to be parents
who love God and hide his word in our hearts. If we love God and we're mulling over his word,
then that is what is going to spill over into our relationships with our children.
His love is going to overflow into the life of our homes and his word that's in us is going to
flow out of our mouths into the lives of our children. So if we're going to love and
care for our children like we're called to it must begin with our relationship with God.
So let's end here. Do you know the love of your heavenly Father?
Are you receiving his love for you in Jesus? Are you listening to what he wants to teach you?
Are you relying on him? I realize speaking about parents and children can hit different
ones of us in different ways but just know this that you are invited to come and rest
in the love of your Father who loves you more than you can fathom. He loved you so much he was
willing to give his son. If you feel like a failure as a parent come and know the love of your
heavenly Father in Jesus or maybe you would grieve the lack of encouragement that you were
not given by your parents will come and know the encouragement and acceptance of your Father
who loves you this much. See Jesus the perfect Son laid down his life for us that we might be
welcomed into the family of God and know and experience the love of a perfect Father.
The love of our Father satisfies the craving that we have for fatherly love and it's his love
comforts us and enables us to love our children and our parents in ways that look increasingly like
his own. So we're going to come now to the Lord's table together and this is a family meal that we
are sharing together and this meal the bread that is broken and the wine that we will drink
together reminds us of Jesus' body that was broken for us and his blood that was shed for us.
As we're coming to this table we're being reminded of God's great love for us that he has shown us
in Jesus. Before we approach the table this morning I want us to we're going to do something a
little bit different not massively different. We are going to just take a time just in silent
prayer to meditate on our own yes our own sin but also on the love of God revealed to us in
Jesus. So spend time on your own with the Lord and whatever he lays his finger on
and then in the moment I'm going to invite us to to pray together. We have prayers of confession
modeled for us in in scripture and we have a prayer of confession that I have for us in
our worship guides so it's good for us to confess our sins together as a church and so we're
going to confess our sinfulness before God and then I'm going to just read out a couple
places in scripture that speak of God's forgiveness that he has shown us in Jesus and invite us to
behold him and then we'll come to this table together. So let's spend this moment in silent prayer.
So let's come before our merciful God together in confession of sin.
Let's read these words. Most merciful God we confess that we have sinned against you in thought
word indeed by what we have done and by what we have left undone. We have not loved you with
our whole heart. We have not loved our neighbors as ourselves. We are truly sorry and humbly
repent for the sake of your son Jesus Christ. Have mercy on us and forgive us that we may delight
in your will and walk in your ways to the glory of your name. Amen. So hear these words of
pardon and forgiveness in scripture. The word of God says if we confess our sins
God is faithful and just to forgive us of our sins and to cleanse us from all unrighteousness.
It goes on to say that as we look to Christ behold what kind of love the Father has given to us
that we should be called the children of God and so we are. This is the word of the Lord.
Thanks be to God. Lord we thank you so much for welcoming us as your children through Jesus Christ.
Lord we thank you for the love that is portrayed for us in this meal that we shared together
in this broken bread and in this wine. Lord I pray that you would help us to receive this
with yes humility but also with with glad and thankful hearts because of all that you've
done for us. We might be your children but we might share in this meal together as your family.
Pray all this in Jesus name. Amen.